I unexpectedly needed a blood transfusion a few weeks ago,
and my hemoglobin levels were very, very low.
So I have low hemoglobin levels, that's part of anemia.
So 7.7 is very low.
And I highly recommend that if a person has those kind of levels
that getting a blood transfusion is the right thing to do.
I later called the blood bank to learn
if I could have specific people donate blood for me,
like family members for future possible transfusions.
My motivation in part was to have people who did not take
a COVID vaccine donate to me directly.
The blood bank takes it very difficult
to have a donation directed specifically to.
The woman told me that the vaccine is not in the blood,
but then said that they do not even test for this.
My question is, do you think this is true
that the vaccine material mRNA DNA do not circulate
in the bloodstream, but therefore are not
a concern with receiving a blood transfusion
for an unknown donor?
Well, my opinion is that it is in there, and it does affect you.
And we did breach this question a while back.
After the vaccines came out, people were requesting
non-vaccinated blood.
There was some blood banks that did separate that out
with questionnaires from the patient.
They were testing the blood.
They were asking the patient's questions
where you vaccinated that blood did get separated out.
I don't know if every blood bank has that availability,
obviously it doesn't because we just experienced that.
I don't know that even the blood banks that did have that
separation of that availability still have that availability.
Maybe if you were in the 1% elite, you could get anything
you wanted.
I just saw that the 1% elite that were traveling to Davos
to the World Economic Forum's climate change summit
that's coming up are all requesting demanding
non-vaccinated pilots to fly their private jets.
They won't fly with vaccinated pilots.
So I don't want to offend anybody that's listening to this
that didn't get the COVID vaccine.
But if you listen to me long enough, I think that was a great mistake.
There's very big dangers in that COVID vaccine.
There's dangers in any vaccine.
This one is the worst.
Followed closely by a few others.
But this is a horrible vaccine.
It's not even a vaccine.
It is a DNA danger tool is what it is.
And it is, I just, it's, you know, you are exposed.
And even if you never got the vaccine,
you're still probably if testing was available to know if there's
mRNA or this DNA fragments from the vaccine in your blood,
I'd probably test positive for it.
You would too, even if you didn't get a transfusion
and didn't get the vaccine, because there's so much cross-tamination
and because there's so much contamination through, you know,
anybody that you come in contact with.
So, you know, I'm not sure that we're not all contaminated.
But then you have to weigh out the pros and cons of, okay,
do I not get a blood transfusion?
Which could save my life and really help me get over
this giant hump that I'm dealing with so that I can continue
on with other treatment.
If I was in your situation, I would probably get the blood.
There's, you, like I've told you in the past, you know,
a gun to my head and I would still say no to the COVID vaccine.
So, it is a concern for those that are trying to be more diligent
at, you know, and have both physiological reasons
and moral reasons, not to get exposed to this vaccine.
But there's some things that are beyond our control
and there's nothing you can do.